das ist echt hart sein eigenes schwester
flaschen blutzuckers haltbarkeit
möglicherweise ermordet wurde
sie wurde mit einem betonklotz in der
weser versenkt sie waren nackt und die
knoten waren extrem kompliziert wir
reden über über komplizierte bondage
knoten
müssen wir die aufgewachsen so das ist
das einzige was gott geschenkt hat man
hat ein seltsames eine seltsame
situation aus beziehungstat aber auch
klaren bezügen zur illegalen
prostitution gehört aus diesem zuhälter
wir sind brutaler zuhälter ist ob ich
gehört so der so viel wie in der hölle
schmoren das wünsche ich nur 5 hier
besteht kaum ein zweifel dass das nicht
wahr was impulsiv aus einem streit
heraus spontan passiert ist sondern dass
dies eine geplante ein geplanter mord
oder man muss leider fast auch sagen in
richtung machen
[Musik]